hey hey what's up my fellow geeks zacky
here bringing you another fantastic
video this time we're gonna show you how
to connect your ps5 to your ipad for
remote play just a few simple steps of
course what i have here is the new
midnight black ps5 dual sense controller
boy does that look so good isn't it nice
to finally see some color
now of course we just go over to
settings
go over to system
go to remote play
and make sure that remote play is
enabled
now all we need to do is just head over
to the ipad now that we're on the ipad
i'm using the ipad pro 2021 of course
make sure that playstation remote play
is installed go ahead and open it and
the first thing we want to check is to
make sure that both the ipad and
the ps5 are both connected to the same
wi-fi network
now of course once that is all done just
sign in to your playstation network
account
now it's gonna prompt you on about some
data privacy stuff just go ahead and
continue and then
it's gonna prompt you on how to pair the
bluetooth function of your ps5 dual sets
controller to the ipad all you need to
do is to press and hold the playstation
button
and the create button for three seconds
and if that's successful you would see
that the leds on the touchpad are
blinking
and what you want to do is to go back to
your ipad
open up bluetooth settings
and you should be able to see the
dualsense wireless controllers under
other devices
go ahead and connect to that
that's done your ps5 is now connected to
the ipad
so before we head on and enjoy remote
play there are few settings that we need
to double check so go on and tap on the
gear icon
now you will see a few settings here
first thing we want to check is video
quality for remote play
make sure that the ps5 has hdr
on automatic
next is the resolution we want that in
720p
and we want the frame rate to be high
now once that's all checked you're good
to go baby go ahead and connect it and
you would see the ps5 prompt
that you're using remote play
as simple as that it can start enjoying
all your favorite games
anywhere as long as you're in the same
network so you can play in the bathroom
you can play and the bedroom
anywhere of course the ps5 and the ipad
pro do have wi-fi six so you can see
that there's seamless gameplay with
remote play
i won't say it's zero lag but it's close
enough
check out that cosmic red dual sense
controller
[Music]
just another beauty shot for you guys so
you can see the midnight black and the
cosmic ray 2 sense controller together
and with that we hope you enjoyed this
video hope you found it useful
do let us know in the comments down
below what do you think of remote play
do give us a like and subscribe to the
channel helps us a lot and we have some
ratchet and clan gameplay videos on our
gaming channel as well so do check them
out
see you on the next one
[Music]
[Music]
you